Générique
...
- Kathia Gilder:
Bonjour et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro
de "Parlement hebdo".
Nous sommes ensemble
pour 26 minutes
pour voir le meilleur
de l'actu politique
et parlementaire
de la semaine
avec notre invité.
- Alexandre Poussart:
C'est Loïc Hervé.
Vous êtes sénateur centriste
de la Haute-Savoie
et vice-président du Sénat.
- Kathia Gilder: On va voir
la une de cette semaine.
Après une attente interminable,
le gouvernement est complet.
Principal changement:
Nicole Belloubet
remplace Amélie Oudéa-Castéra
à l'Education nationale.
Le refus de François Bayrou
d'entrer au gouvernement
a provoqué un début
de crise dans la majorité.
Le Parlement veut
mieux protéger les élus.
L'Assemblée nationale
vient de voter
une proposition de loi
d'origine sénatoriale.
Elle prévoit
un durcissement des sanctions
envers les agresseurs d'élus.
On reparle de la loi immigration.
Des sénateurs centristes
et Les Républicains déposent
chacun un texte pour remettre
sur la table certaines mesures
qui avaient été retoquées
par le Conseil constitutionnel
- Alexandre Poussart:
Après un mois d'attente,
on connaît enfin la composition
complète du gouvernement.
- L'heure des ajustements a sonné.
Un mois après sa nomination,
Gabriel Attal a étoffé
son exécutif.
Au premier rang,
deux ministres de plein exercice
complètent l'équipe
gouvernementale
pour porter son nombre
à 16 membres.
Nicole Belloubet, ancienne
garde des Sceaux jusqu'en 2020,
déleste Amélie Oudéa-Castéra
de l'Education nationale.
Elle conserve
le Sports et les JO.
Stanislas Guerini retrouve
un mois plus tard son portefeuille
de la Transformation
et de la Fonction publiques.
Ce jeudi,
c'est principalement
le casting
de ministres délégués
et secrétaires d'Etat
qui était attendu.
Là encore,
peu de changements.
Roland Lescure, Olivia Grégoire
et Thomas Cazenave
retrouvent leurs fonctions passées,
tout comme Dominique Faure, chargée
des Collectivités territoriales,
Hervé Berville à la Mer
ou Sabrina Agresti-Roubache,
chargée de la Ville
et de la Citoyenneté.
Parmi les nouveaux visages,
Frédéric Valletoux,
député Horizons,
viendra prêter main-forte
à Catherine Vautrin
au ministère de la Santé.
Guillaume Kasbarian récupère
le ministère du Logement.
Enfin, Marina Ferrari,
députée MoDem de Savoie,
sera en charge du Numérique.
Malgré sa colère froide,
François Bayrou conserve
quatre donc maroquins ministériels.
Un exécutif de 35 membres,
Premier ministre compris,
soit 7 de moins
que dans la dernière équipe Borne.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Loïc Hervé,
on a attendu un mois
pour avoir la composition complète
de ce gouvernement.
Tout ça pour ça?
- Loïc Hervé:
C'est un peu la réaction
qu'on peut avoir en découvrant
ce nouveau gouvernement,
qui, à part
des ajustements marginaux
et des changements
de portefeuille
pour un certain nombre
de ministres,
voit arriver
quelques personnalités nouvelles.
Avoir pris un mois
et avoir gâché
le début du mandat
de Gabriel Attal,
c'est un peu dommage.
Le gouvernement a mis du temps
à être au complet.
Le Premier ministre
a pris du temps
pour faire son discours
de politique générale.
Dans l'intervalle,
il y a eu cette question
de la grande conférence
du président de la République.
Ce feuilletonnage
du mois de janvier,
on en sort avec un peu
d'interrogation, quand même.
Le pays n'a pas besoin de ça.
Le pays a besoin
d'une ligne claire, d'un rythme.
Ce rythme du mois de janvier
n'a pas été tout à fait
à la hauteur,
y compris sur les travaux
parlementaires,
qui est quand même un sujet
qui nous intéresse ici.
C'est une interrogation pour nous.
- Kathia Gilder: Nicole Belloubet,
l'un des principaux changements,
devient ministre
de l'Education nationale.
Elle était garde des Sceaux
lors du premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron.
Voilà ce que dit Bruno Retailleau,
patron des sénateurs LR, d'elle:
"Elle était une des ministres
de la Justice
les plus laxistes
de la Ve République."
Est-ce selon vous le bon profil
pour incarner l'autorité à l'école?
- Loïc Hervé: Je ne sais pas.
On va pouvoir ressortir tout un tas
de déclarations de madame Belloubet
sur tout un tas de sujets
qui sont en lien avec l'école.
Ce qui est certain,
c'est que l'Education nationale
ne peut pas se réformer
contre les enseignants.
La situation
entre Amélie Oudéa-Castéra
et ses déclarations malheureuses
de tout début de fonctions
et le corps enseignant faisait
que la situation était inextricable.
Le gouvernement
est maintenant composé
avec Nicole Belloubet
qui a été garde des Sceaux.
Je n'en garde pas un souvenir
extraordinaire.
Il y a une question d'incarnation.
- Kathia Gilder:
Là, c'était pour apaiser.
- Loïc Hervé: L'école est
quand même le sujet des sujets.
- Kathia Gilder:
Gabriel Attal veut
un retour de l'autorité
à l'école.
- Loïc Hervé: D'autant plus
que le Premier ministre
est resté six mois
dans ce ministère.
Vous pouvez apaiser,
mais vous devez réformer
avec les enseignants.
Je m'interroge.
Je pense que madame Belloubet
aura des preuves à nous apporter
de sa capacité à recréer
de la confiance
et à porter les réformes
dont l'école française a besoin.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Vous parlez
de ses anciennes déclarations
à propos de l'affaire Mila,
cette lycéenne qui avait été menacée
de mort pour avoir critiqué l'islam.
Nicole Belloubet avait déclaré
que l'insulte à la religion
était une atteinte
à la liberté de conscience.
Cette déclaration
avait fait un tollé.
Est-ce que sa nomination
est un mauvais signal envoyé
par rapport à l'objectif
de la lutte pour la laïcité
et contre le harcèlement à l'école?
- Loïc Hervé: Il faudra
que madame Belloubet,
lors des premières semaines,
clarifie ses positions.
La question de l'autorité
républicaine à l'école publique
est une question fondamentale,
notamment pour les élèves.
On fabrique dans notre école
des citoyens responsables.
La manière dont on transmet
certaines valeurs
à l'école républicaine
est fondamentale.
Là-dessus, le briefing du
Premier ministre sera assez clair.
- Kathia Gilder: Le portefeuille
de l'Education nationale
a été retiré du périmètre
d'Amélie Oudéa-Castéra,
qui reste au ministère des Sports.
Est-ce que le gouvernement a cédé
à la pression des syndicats?
- Loïc Hervé: Ce n'est pas
tellement la question.
Quand vous êtes ministre
de l'Education nationale,
c'est-à-dire
que vous êtes ministre
de l'école publique et laïque,
vous devez avoir une posture,
une incarnation
qui fait que vous êtes le chef,
la cheffe,
en l'occurrence, d'une très grande
administration française.
Une très grande administration
très ancienne qui porte
un certain nombre de choses.
Les justifications
pour lesquelles
vous avez mis vos enfants
dans une école catholique
sous contrat,
cela crée du trouble.
Je suis bien placé pour le savoir.
La question
de la scolarisation
de vos enfants
est un choix individuel
non contestable.
Ce n'est pas ça, le sujet.
Le sujet, c'est le message envoyé.
Ce n'était pas rattrapable.
Les syndicats ont utilisé
cette situation,
mais je pense
que la situation
dans laquelle
était Amélie Oudéa-Castéra
était inextricable
pour le gouvernement.
C'était plutôt sain
de faire un changement.
A madame Belloubet de prouver
qu'elle est la bonne personne.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il y en a un
qui a refusé d'entrer
au gouvernement,
c'est François Bayrou,
à cause d'un désaccord profond
autour du ministère
de l'Education nationale.
- Je suis persuadé
qu'on peut redresser
le ministère
de l'Education nationale
en peu d'années,
cela demande un choix politique
qui est de faire ça
avec les enseignants
et les autres parties
prenantes de l'école.
- Ce n'est pas le cas
de la personne qui a été nommée?
- On est sur une musique de fond,
qui est:
les enseignants
ne travaillent pas assez.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Ce cas François Bayrou,
c'est une affaire personnelle
d'un poids lourd de la majorité
qui n'a pas eu le poste
qu'il escomptait?
Ou c'est le signe
d'une crise plus profonde?
- Loïc Hervé:
Ce qui se passe
dans le bureau
de Gabriel Attal
avec François Bayrou
m'intéresse assez peu.
En revanche,
quand François Bayrou
prend la parole, moi
qui suis d'un parti centriste,
je l'écoute toujours.
Il a souvent une forme
de prémonition
ou une sorte de diagnostic
sur le mal français,
qui me fait toujours réfléchir.
Je ne suis pas toujours
d'accord
avec lui, mais
c'est une très grande figure
de la vie politique française,
incontestablement.
Ce qu'il exprime
dans ce moment-là
de notre vie politique,
on ferait mieux
de l'écouter
sans caricaturer
ce qu'il a à dire
à titre personnel.
Evidemment, le sujet
de sa non-entrée
au gouvernement interroge.
Ce qu'il dit
de l'école française,
on ferait bien de l'entendre.
Les élections présidentielles
sont dans trois ans et demi.
Ca va être long.
C'est important d'entendre cela.
- Kathia Gilder:
François Bayrou candidat pour 2027,
il vous paraîtrait être
le bon candidat pour le centre?
- Loïc Hervé: C'est encore
trop tôt pour le dire.
J'ai fait trois campagnes
présidentielles
de François Bayrou,
je sais de quoi je parle.
Il a joué un rôle
politique important.
Il aura une voix qui comptera.
Je dirais même, il est
une personnalité incontournable.
On l'aime ou on ne l'aime pas,
ce n'est pas le sujet.
On verra bien comment
les choses vont tourner.
On verra bien un an avant
les élections présidentielles.
Bien évidemment il faut l'écouter.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il a raison quand il parle
d'une déconnexion entre les élites,
l'Etat, et le peuple français?
- Loïc Hervé: Nous la vivons
tous les jours.
L'organisation
des institutions françaises
fait que cela conduit
au risque de la rupture,
de cette coupure
entre le pays réel et les élus.
Si vous n'en avez pas
conscience
et si vous ne faites pas
un effort
sur vous-même
dans l'exercice de votre mandat,
vous vous coupez
de la réalité des Français.
François Bayrou l'a dit
sur les ondes de Franceinfo.
C'est important
de l'avoir en tête.
- Kathia Gilder: Si on se projette
sur l'agenda parlementaire,
il n'y a pas encore de textes
très importants
à l'ordre du jour du Parlement.
Or Gabriel Attal a dit qu'il voulait
avoir des résultats rapides.
Vous craignez qu'il contourne
le Parlement?
- Loïc Hervé:
Il n'aura pas le choix.
Dans notre pays,
on a une Constitution.
On a un président du Sénat
qui va regarder ça
avec beaucoup d'attention
et de vigilance.
Je vais vous donner un exemple.
Quand vous faites des réunions
dans les départements
où les préfets vont rencontrer
les agriculteurs
pour parler
de l'assouplissement des normes
et que vous faites ces réunions
le mercredi
pour que les parlementaires
ne viennent pas, on commence mal.
Un certain nombre
de ces assouplissements
passeront par la loi.
Donc le Parlement
est incontournable.
Le risque,
ce n'est pas tellement
le contournement.
Le risque,
c'est l'effacement.
La majorité présidentielle
n'a la majorité
ni à l'Assemblée ni au Sénat.
Il faudra discuter
avec les formations politiques,
avec les groupes politiques
du Parlement
à l'Assemblée et au Sénat.
Gabriel Attal a pris
un certain nombre d'engagements
devant la conférence
des présidents
à l'Assemblée et au Sénat.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Quels engagements?
- Loïc Hervé:
Des engagements de travail
avec de nombreuses
constructions
de textes
avec les parlementaires.
Le gouvernement écrit le texte,
c'est sa responsabilité.
Ensuite, c'est le Parlement
qui vote la loi.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Un texte symbolique
est à l'ordre du jour
au Parlement:
l'introduction dans la Constitution
de la liberté garantie
de recourir à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse.
Ca été voté
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Au Sénat, l'issue du vote
est incertaine.
Vous, vous êtes contre.
N'y a-t-il pas un risque
pour la majorité de droite
et de centre du Sénat,
si elle rejette cette réforme,
d'apparaître comme rétrograde?
- Loïc Hervé:
Si on place ce débat
sur le plan
de l'air du temps,
on est à côté de l'exercice.
C'est l'actualité américaine
qui nous fait légiférer
sur ce sujet.
La Cour suprême
américaine a décidé
il y a près de 50 ans
de rendre l'IVG fédérale,
et elle est revenue
sur cette décision
très récemment.
Mettre cette rédaction
dans la Constitution,
c'est donner des pouvoirs
au Conseil constitutionnel
qui sont considérables.
Le Conseil constitutionnel
est renforcé depuis 2008.
Dans la mesure
où il n'existe pas
de protection de la clause
de conscience
des professionnels de santé
sur la question
de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse,
pour ma part,
je ne voterai pas
le fait de transférer
l'appréciation
au Conseil constitutionnel.
Les membres
du Conseil constitutionnel
ne sont pas élus,
ils sont nommés
par les hautes autorités
de l'Etat.
- Kathia Gilder: On suivra ce débat
au Sénat fin février.
Jusqu'à sept ans
d'emprisonnement
et 100.000 euros d'amende
contre les auteurs de violences
envers les élus:
les députés ont adopté
une proposition de loi
venue du Sénat pour renforcer
la sécurité des élus,
notamment des maires.
- L'objectif est simple:
mieux protéger
les élus contre les violences.
- L'élu local,
et le maire en particulier,
est à portée d'engueulade,
mais il ne doit pas
être à portée
de baffe, d'insulte,
de diffamation.
- Les agressions contre les élus
sont en augmentation:
+15 % entre 2022 et 2023.
- Si chaque agression
est individuellement
insupportable,
la croissance de leur nombre
rend le phénomène
absolument intolérable.
2265 agressions d'élus en 2022.
2600 en 2023.
- La proposition de loi
vise à aligner
le régime des sanctions
en cas de violence
contre les élus locaux sur celui
des personnes dépositaires
de l'autorité publique,
comme les policiers.
Autre avancée:
l'octroi automatique
de la protection fonctionnelle
aux maires et aux élus municipaux
avec un mandat exécutif
en cas d'agression ou d'injure.
Une disposition
a fait polémique:
le passage
de trois mois à un an
des délais de prescription
en cas d'injure
et de diffamation publique
contre un élu ou un candidat.
Certains ont exprimé leur crainte
pour la liberté de la presse.
- Il y a une disposition
qui nous inquiète particulièrement
et qui inquiète aussi
les journalistes,
c'est le délai
de prescription
qui a été posé et qui nous pose
un réel problème.
- Après le Sénat,
la proposition de loi
a été largement
adoptée à l'Assemblée.
Une autre réforme,
celle du statut de l'élu local,
est prévue
dans les prochains mois.
- Kathia Gilder:
Les agressions contre les élus
sont en hausse.
Plus de 2200 agressions en 2022.
Est-ce que cette loi va permettre
d'arrêter ces violences?
- Loïc Hervé: En tout cas,
elle y contribuera.
Ces agressions
contre les élus,
j'en ai moi-même été l'objet
quand j'étais maire.
- Kathia Gilder:
Agressions importantes?
- Loïc Hervé:
Menace de mort,
protection des gendarmes
pendant trois semaines,
interpellation
de la personne,
qui a été condamnée
à un an de prison.
Je l'ai vu en vrai.
En France, un certain
nombre d'élus vivent
sous les menaces,
sous les insultes
et sous les agressions physiques.
Cette question-là,
c'est une question
de possibilité
pour la République
de fonctionner normalement.
Cet ensauvagement de notre société
se révèle aussi
dans ces relations
qu'il y a entre certains
de nos concitoyens et les élus.
La loi pénale
doit être renforcée,
c'est très bien.
Il y a aussi la manière
dont les élus
sont capables
de continuer
d'avoir des relations
avec les habitants.
Il ne s'agit pas
de couper le lien.
Il ne s'agit pas de s'enfermer
dans les institutions
pour ne plus avoir de contact
avec les habitants.
La vie citoyenne
doit être garantie par la loi.
Ce que le Sénat a voulu faire
et ce que les députés ont voté
très récemment,
c'est de rappeler
le rôle incontournable
des élus dans ce pays.
Quand il a fallu
sortir le pays
de la crise des gilets
jaunes, le président
de la République
a eu besoin des maires.
La contrepartie
aujourd'hui,
c'est de leur rendre
la possibilité
d'accomplir leur mandat
dans la paix publique.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Ce texte augmente
de trois mois à un an
le délai de prescription
dans les affaires
de diffamation
ou d'injure publique
contre un élu.
Il y a souvent des élus
qui portent plainte
contre des médias,
contre des journaux,
sur certains articles.
Est-ce que c'est une atteinte
à la liberté de la presse,
vous qui êtes attaché
aux libertés?
- Loïc Hervé:
Ce n'est pas une atteinte
à la liberté de la presse
que de décaler
de quelques mois un délai
de prescription.
Ca ne me choque absolument pas.
Je viens de déposer plainte
contre une personne
qui publie
tous les jours des choses
me concernant.
J'ai saisi le procureur
de la République.
Les délais
sont extrêmement courts.
Si on est sur d'autres notions
de cyberharcèlement,
c'est d'autres délais.
Une des choses dont on ne parle pas
dans cette affaire,
c'est que beaucoup d'élus
ne portent pas plainte.
Beaucoup d'élus vivent
avec ces insultes.
J'ai toujours réussi
à faire condamner
des personnes
qui s'en sont prises à moi.
J'ai toujours été
intransigeant là-dessus.
Il faut accompagner
les élus
dans leur dépôt de plainte.
Le rôle des procureurs
est énorme en la matière.
C'est eux qui ont la maîtrise
des poursuites
à l'égard de ceux
qui s'en prennent aux élus.
C'est à eux, en termes
de politique pénale,
de jouer ce rôle.
- Kathia Gilder:
Il y a de nombreux maires
qui démissionnent
face à ces violences extrêmes.
Comment vous faites éviter une crise
de l'engagement municipal?
- Loïc Hervé: En réenchantant
la démocratie locale
et en changeant la manière
dont l'Etat s'adresse
et se comporte
vis-à-vis des élus.
L'Etat exécutif,
l'Etat "parisien".
500.000 élus locaux
se lèvent tous les matins
pour s'occuper
de leurs compatriotes.
Il faut les respecter.
- Kathia Gilder:
On va parler d'immigration.
Les sénateurs centristes
et les sénateurs LR déposent
chacun une proposition de loi
pour réintroduire
les mesures de durcissement
de la loi
qui avaient été retoquées
par le Conseil constitutionnel.
- Nous avons repris
les articles
que le Conseil constitutionnel
avait jugés
comme étant des cavaliers,
c'est-à-dire qui n'avaient pas
leur place dans la loi.
On a refait
une proposition de loi.
On verra, le moment venu,
s'il y a lieu de la discuter.
A un moment ou un autre,
il faudra compléter le texte
déjà voté.
- Nous ne sommes pas restés
les bras ballants.
A la base du projet
de loi immigration,
il y avait déjà
une proposition de loi portée
par Les Républicains,
par François-Noël Buffet.
Nous allons, effectivement,
redéposer la proposition de loi
un petit peu modifiée
par rapport
à ce qui a déjà été voté.
Cette proposition de loi
aura une antériorité
au regard de ce qu'ont
fait les centristes.
- Il y aura bataille
de propositions de loi
dans la majorité sénatoriale.
- Alexandre Poussart:
C'est vraiment nécessaire
de remettre sur la table ce sujet
de l'immigration?
- Loïc Hervé:
Il ne s'agit pas de remettre
sur la table le sujet
de l'immigration.
Le sujet de l'accueil
des immigrés en France
est un sujet permanent,
dont le Parlement doit être saisi
de manière constante.
Le débat a eu lieu
dans notre pays
dans des conditions
très difficiles.
Le seul débat parlementaire
a eu lieu au Sénat,
du fait de ce qui s'est passé
à l'Assemblée nationale.
La motion de rejet a fait en sorte
que le débat n'ait pas lieu.
Ce texte a été mal construit
et mal voté.
Il manque une des deux parties
du texte.
Ca a conduit
le Conseil constitutionnel
à prendre une décision.
Beaucoup de dispositions
ont été écartées
parce qu'elles n'étaient pas
conformes à la Constitution
et beaucoup de dispositions
parce qu'elles étaient considérées
comme cavaliers législatifs.
C'est tout à fait normal
que les deux groupes
de la majorité sénatoriale,
le groupe centriste
et le groupe LR,
forts de leur sensibilité,
déposent ce qui leur paraît
le plus important
dans ces dispositions écartées
par le Conseil constitutionnel.
Je ne vois pas pourquoi
on interdirait au Parlement
de continuer de débattre
sur ce sujet.
Nous continuerons
à le faire
dans le cadre
de la majorité sénatoriale
et dans le cadre
du débat démocratique.
- Kathia Gilder: En tout cas,
le patron des députés Renaissance
à l'Assemblée
était notre invité
la semaine dernière
et a dit que la loi immigration
était derrière nous,
laissant entendre que ses députés
ne voteraient pas un nouveau texte.
Ca veut dire que ce débat
n'a aucune chance d'aboutir?
- Loïc Hervé:
Ce n'est pas le président
du groupe Renaissance
qui décide de l'ordre du jour
du Parlement
et encore moins de l'ordre
du jour du Sénat.
Nous discutons
avec le gouvernement,
d'autant plus qu'il est maintenant
au complet, sur ces sujets.
Il y a eu un deal politique
qui a été passé
et qui fait
qu'un certain nombre
de dispositions ont reçu
des avis favorables
du gouvernement au Sénat.
J'étais président
de séance
d'une partie de ce texte.
Des amendements
qui ont été votés
avec un avis favorable
du gouvernement au Sénat
doivent être des amendements
qui peuvent faire partie
du débat démocratique.
Nous devons continuer
à aborder ces sujets.
Il y a des sujets sur lesquels
je suis beaucoup moins à l'aise,
comme la question
de la caution des étudiants.
- Alexandre Poussart: Une caution
pour les étudiants étrangers,
plus précisément.
Les sénateurs LR y sont favorables.
- Loïc Hervé: C'est leur droit,
et c'est aussi notre droit
d'être contre.
Cette mesure a été écartée
par le Conseil constitutionnel.
Continuons le débat.
Aucun débat n'est interdit.
Quand vous
avez l'extrême droite
qui caracole en tête
des sondages
pour les élections européennes,
l'idée de dire que
le sujet migratoire n'est pas
un sujet et qu'on n'en parlera plus,
je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit un bon signal
à envoyer à l'opinion publique.
- Kathia Gilder: Et la réforme de
l'AME mais par voie réglementaire.
- Loïc Hervé:
C'est une bonne chose.
Vous avez deux articles dans la loi:
l'article 34,
c'est le domaine de la loi,
et l'article 37, c'est
les prérogatives du gouvernement.
- Kathia Gilder: Ca permet
d'être efficace?
- Loïc Hervé: Oui. C'est très bien
que le gouvernement assume
le fait qu'il y ait
des choses à régler dans l'AME.
- Alexandre Poussart:
L'aide médicale d'Etat
qui permet de soigner les étrangers
en situation irrégulière.
- Kathia Gilder:
Merci d'avoir été notre invité.